es handelt sich um eine tickende
zeitbombe und da ist der zusammenbruch
des golfstroms systems hätte für uns
schwer wiegende folgen der golfstrom
gehört mit so einem wichtigen
meeresströmung system im atlantik und
steht kurz vor dem kollaps so das
alarmierende ergebnis einer aktuellen
studie aus deutschland für ganz europa
hätte das tiefgreifende folgen klicks
zum science im future geht es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
ging's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank an
jakob für diesen themen vorschlag der
uns über unsere talibangruppe erreicht
hat der link dazu ist ihr untermieter
kriegt ihr auch die videos früher und
könnt mitdiskutieren die folgen wären
verheerend wenn der golfstrom
tatsächlich zusammenbricht wird ganz
europa massive auswirkungen zu spüren
bekommen fachleute rechnen mit großen
umwälzungen wettersystem zu den hitze
extrem wie sie derzeit in südeuropa
herrschen game extreme kälteeinbrüche
trocken und regenzeiten würden sich
abwechseln und nicht nur für die wälder
sondern auch die landwirtschaft wäre das
eine riesige herausforderung es würde
schwierig werden hier in europa
lebensmittel anzubauen die folgen wären
dramatisch und tatsächlich sind wir gar
nicht so weit von diesem horrorszenario
entfernt ein forschungsteam vom
potsdamer institut für
klimafolgenforschung offenbart jetzt in
einer aktuellen studie den schlimmen
status quo demnach schwächen sich die
meeresströmung im atlantik ab und
könnten schon bald den gefürchteten kipp
punkt erreicht haben woran das genau
liegt was uns im worst case szenario
droht und ob wir dieses noch verhindern
können das alles und noch viel mehr gibt
es jetzt hier bei pixum science in
future der golfstrom eine art warmwasser
heizung und klima motor für europa der
golfstrom versorgt europa mit so viel
wärme wie es
250.000 kernkraftwerke schaffen könnten
im großen und ganzen haben wir es in
mittel und nordeuropa also dem golfstrom
zu verdanken dass vor allem im winter
eher milde temperaturen herrschen ohne
ihn wäre es in nord- und nordwesteuropa
im durchschnitt bis zu zehn grad kälter
so heißt es in manchen schätzungen dann
sähe die landschaft eher so aus wie in
kanada karg und eis bedeckt statt grüner
wiesen und wälder die mündung der elbe
in hamburg beispielsweise wäre wohl wie
der hudson bay monatelang vereins doch
warum hat der golfstrom so große
auswirkungen auf das klima in europa das
strömungs system kommt aus der karibik
genaugenommen den bahamas auf seinem weg
erwärmt sich das wasser auf bis zu 30
grad celsius und seine wirkung zeigt
sich bis zur küste norwegens den
golfstrom kann man sich vorstellen wie
eine riesige umwälzpumpe denn zum einen
fließt nahe an der oberfläche warmes
tropisches wasser über den atlantik in
richtung europa aus dem nordatlantik
strom verdunstet wasser die
salzkonzentration des meeres steigt
zudem kühlt sich der strom ab beide
faktoren führen dazu dass das wasser
dichter und schwerer wird es singt in
die tiefsee hin ab und gelangt zurück
nach südwesten bis zum südatlantik und
zwar als kalte tiefen strömung somit
verbindet der golfstrom vier der fünf
ozeane miteinander forschungsteams
bezeichnen ihn auch als das globale
förderband von meeresströmungen das
absinken des wassers passiert vor allem
in den nördlichen breiten der labrador
und der grönlandsee 17 millionen
kubikmeter wasser pro sekunde
stürzen in eine tiefe von bis zu 4000
metern der größte wasserfall der welt
und zwar zwischen grönland und
spitzbergen tatsächlich 15 mal so viel
wasser wie alle flüsse der welt zusammen
durch dieses absinken des wassers
entsteht ein sog und eben der zieht den
golfstrom richtung europa schon seit
vielen jahren zerbrechen sich fachleute
weltweit den kopf darüber inwieweit der
klimawandel den golfstrom beeinflusst im
hinterkopf immer die frage ob sogar die
gefahr besteht dass er komplett ab reißt
eine frage die tatsächlich entscheidend
für das leben auf der erde sein könnte
es gibt viele verschiedene
modellrechnungen aber eines ist ganz
sicher der klimawandel hat auswirkungen
auf den golfstrom und es sind mehrere
faktoren des klimawandels die den
golfstrom schwächen und lahmlegen
könnten zum einen erwärmt die steigende
globale temperatur das wasser dieses
wird leichter das strömungs system
verliert an antrieb und weniger warmes
wasser gelangt nach nordeuropa auch das
abschmelzen der pole und des
grönlandeises lässt das wasser im
endeffekt leichter werden denn dadurch
nimmt der salzgehalt des meerwassers ab
eine weitere rolle spielt das der
permafrostböden wodurch sibirischen
flüsse mehr süßwasser in die nördlichen
meere spült im vergleich zur eisschmelze
wohl aber nur ein kleiner faktor immer
wieder auch die diskussion in der
fachwelt wie fatal die folgen wohl sein
könnten wenn der golfstrom tatsächlich
kollabiert in früheren analysen könnte
sich der strom um höchstens 20 prozent
abschwächen selbst wenn sich die
konzentration gegenüber der
vorindustriellen zeit verdoppeln würde
die sogenannte atlantic mehr regional
over trainingssession am ort zu der auch
der golfstrom gehört ist demnach
ziemlich stabil so die annahme andere
aktuellere studien dagegen behaupten das
gegenteil
demnach könnten die risiken strömungen
sogar komplett abreißen wenn sich der
co2 gehalt verdoppelt klar ist
jedenfalls die ozeane speichern eine
große menge energie und das ist auch der
grund warum die strömung in den meeren
einen großen effekt auf das erdklima
haben im vergangenen jahr hatte ein
niederländisches forschungsteam bereits
eindringlich davor gewarnt dass sich der
zustand des stromes durch den
klimawandel bereits in der nahen zukunft
verändern könnte die fachleute hatten
genauer analysiert wie sich der
klimawandel konkret auf den strom
auswirkt und zwar in einer aufwändigen
simulationen hier ging es hauptsächlich
um die frage wie das zunehmende
süßwasser auf die ströme wirkt das
ergebnis des forschungsteams besteht aus
zwei wesentlichen erkenntnissen zunächst
die gute ein kompletter stillstand des
golfstroms durch kleine und schnelle
niederschlags änderung über dem
nordatlantik schien damals eher als
unwahrscheinlich
das risiko aber dass sich der zustand
des stroms in den kommenden 100 jahren
zumindest temporär ändert beziffern die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
allerdings auf 15 prozent konkret sei zu
erwarten dass zeitweise weniger relativ
warmes wasser nach nord westeuropa
transportiert wird und selbst eine
geringe abschwächung des stroms könnte
für kälteeinbrüche im nordatlantik
sorgen jetzt sorgt eine neue studie vom
potsdamer institut für
klimafolgenforschung für aufregung das
forschungsteam offenbart dass die
atlantische umwelt strömung an den tick
mehr regional- ober- turning the
collection kurzem auch im laufe des
letzten jahrhunderts an stabilität
verloren hat und dazu gehört auch der
golfstrom demnach steht dieses äußerst
wichtige meeresströmung system im
atlantik deutlich näher vor dem zusatz
bruch als die fachwelt es befürchtet
hatte die aktuelle untersuchung liegt
jetzt nahe dass es sich bei der massiven
abschwächung zurzeit nicht um eine
natürliche fluktuation handelt die sich
im rahmen des aktuellen zirkulation des
zustandes bewegt die neuen ergebnisse
aus potsdam legen stattdessen nahe dass
es sich tatsächlich um eine kritische
schwelle handel zitat jenseits derer das
zirkulation system zusammenbrechen
könnte bereits in der vergangenheit
hatte man also mit der hilfe von
computersimulationen festgestellt dass
die amok zwei verschiedene zustände
einnehmen kann den aktuellen und einen
deutlich schwächeren zustand zwischen
beiden sind nach meinung der fachleute
auch zitat abrupte übergänge denkbar
doch warum ist das system so schwach wie
seit 1000 jahren nicht mehr die aktuelle
studie offenbart also dass es sich hier
leider nicht um eine natürliche
fluktuation handelt das forschungsteam
um den wissenschaftler nicholas burns
hatte für diese analyse die temperatur
und salzgehalt muster der
meeresoberfläche des atlantiks näher ins
visier genommen das fazit der aktuellen
studie die ergebnisse stützen die
einschätzung dass der rückgang der amor
nicht nur eine fluktuation oder eine
lineare reaktion auf steigende
temperaturen ist sondern wahrscheinlich
das herannahen einer kritischen schwelle
bedeutet jenseits derer das zirkulation
system zusammenbrechen könnte dass sich
das system abschwächt ist laut des
forschungsteams dem klimawandel
zuzuschreiben der von uns menschen zu
verantworten ist der hauptfaktor dafür
dass sich das stromsystem abschwächt
liegt im abschmelzen des eispanzers in
grönland begründet und dieses eis
schmilzt wegen der erderwärmung wodurch
extrem viel süßwasser in den
nordatlantik fließt so wird die komplexe
dynamik des golfstroms gestört und kann
wie jetzt gewarnt im schlimmsten fall
schlagartig abbrechen und wieder sind
wir an dem punkt wo die wissenschaft der
politik ganz klar zu verstehen gibt dass
mehr getan werden muss denn auch wenn
niemand ganz genau weiß wann der
entscheidende kipp punkt für den
golfstrom erreicht sein wird muss die
wahrscheinlichkeit dringend verringert
werden dass er eintritt es muss deutlich
schneller und mehr co2 eingespart werden
ansonsten drohen massive folgen und zwar
nicht nur für deutschland nicht nur für
ganz europa für die ganze welt im winter
drohen uns heftigere stürme und im
sommer extreme hitzewellen mit wenig was
genau passieren wird ist noch gar nicht
wirklich abzusehen doch das leben und
dann eher das überleben auf der erde
würde deutlich schwieriger werden island
und skandinavien würde die eisdecke
anwachsen die temperaturen im winter und
bis zu sieben grad absinken dies würde
zum einen die fischerei und damit auch
die wirtschaft beeinträchtigen zum
anderen würde auch das regionale klima
in vielen teilen der welt beeinflusst
beispielsweise in mittel und südamerika
da sich der regen gürtel über dem
tropischen atlantik in richtung süden
verschieben wird aber auch an den
amerikanischen ostküsten würde der
meeresspiegel steigen genauso wie die
zahl der hurricanes jedes gramm co2 das
wir einsparen hilft also hier diese
entwicklung zumindest abzubremsen ein
weg ist zb die elektromobilität mein
neues buch tesla oder wie ihnen masken
die elektromobilität revolutioniert
handelt genau davon ab sofort gibt es
das buch hier bei thalia direkt
lieferbar jetzt direkt hier draufklicken
und bestellen oder ab morgen den 17 8 in
den thalia buchhandlungen schnappt es
euch solange es nicht wieder ausverkauft
ist wenn es noch nicht habt oder jetzt
direkt online dafür einfach hier klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran